This is for my grand-babies again, here's grandpa's story, an army of ants.
Our picnic was swell, Bob Sandwiches too, and grandma made jello that was red-white
and blue.
Aunt Edna brought coleslaw and bread from the oven, and her special recipe of poppy seed
muffin.
Pa spread the red checkerboard, blake it out straight, while I placed some rocks on the
quarter for weight.
Then Hilda, my sister, jumped down in the middle.
About that same time, Uncle Bo grabbed his fiddle.
He'd play a tune happy, so we'd want a dance.
But it was right about then, and I spotted the ants.
I was dumbfounded at first, didn't know what to say.
A whole line of them carried one cupcake away.
They were headed for Pa's special sauce chicken wings, who I tried to ward, but he started
to sing, for the melody Uncle Bo strobed up so well was like magic that caught everyone
in a spell.
My horror was heightened, when I looked once more, I saw 10,000 ants take three pieces, no
four.
Oh, my, what was I, just a young boy to do?
There's more ants than would fit in an entire zoo.
They spotted my favorite cherry parfait.
They're stealing pretty much half our buffet.
The musk melon pretzels.
The white chocolate mousse, my goodness, they've lifted the cooler of juice.
There goes the cucumber salad, Bob, made.
The strawberries didn't stand a chance, I'm afraid.
The barbecue ribs disappeared in a flash, along with just about all of our bash.
That was right about then that I got their attention, all one last thing that I think
I should mention.
When they carried away the last egg for the record, they came back and stole her blanket, all
checkered.
The siggy then stopped, and smiles faded to wonder, who can have caused all the pillage
and plunder.
But before I could speak.
We all looked in surprise, for here came an invasion of thousands of flies.